bon ça va
ouais bon ben oui non c'est pas la peine
de me faire don grands fous rires on dit
11h30 il est minuit moins 10 bah non non
non non pas fumé quoi hein
alors je suis quoi moi je suis une bonne
et je fais une poubelle sur je peux
attendre toute l'année mais là ça n'a
rien à [ __ ] ou par escota de la
télévision eh ben le rôle là il peut se
il peut se les gelait toute la nuit
11h30 je me suis sans heurts et brice
est un mini moins dix morts mais qu en
train de créer des troubles
non seulement ces soirées en plus mais
je vais vous dire moi c'est moi moi je
travaille je fais un boulot je sois moi
personne moi même je suis rabattue ne
soit pas chez toi tu es reposer me
chercher du site
mais qu'est ce que c'est que c'est quoi
la semaine chez moi non plus encore tu
seras mais il est passé chez
l'importateur secret quand mes manches
et surtout que tu tous voulaient faire
combien de temps avec ton émission
bajeux cette ardeur tories minute trente
de plus n'a pas je dors à chez moi à
leurs besoins darien quoi qu'est ce que
tu fais je suis assez bon s'est détendu
voilà qui a pu choquer ce le monde sait
bien c'est bien voilà on est heureux on
est on se rend compte fontaine est mort
alors alors alors quand même ça quand
même pas dur de respecter un horaire
merde et ça s'est bien passé ce soir son
spectacle mais non non ne part pas dans
des questions gentillesse j'y arrive pas
jamais oui et ça s'est bien passé la
soirée était belle jusqu'à ce que tu
jusqu'à ce que tu me [ __ ] 20 minutes
dans le sang était content et oui
j'aime les gens étaient contents les
gens au moins il était à l'heure il est
pourtant loin on leur dit 20h30 théâtre
grévin
ils n'arrivent pas à 23 heures 23 heures
c'est fini ouais oui j'étais dans mon
sens vous êtes content que ça allait oui
ça allait bien mais c'est pas ton petit
ton mielleux tout racheter un peu oui
ben oui j'imagine bien et si une idée
oui allez si on allait au théâtre grenat
écoute je sais pas si tu le mérites
cinq minutes alors après après gendre un
vrai on y va tout de suite alors tu
traînes pas tu me mets pas tout une
équipe et puis on passe pas chez toi on
est d'accord maintenant ça me va
maintenant les gens dont l'agent n'est
d'accord je remarque d'ailleurs alors
allons-y
tu connais le chemin ouais
allez
tu vois un mec avec tes trucs que tu
prêt à
ces gens se trouvent facilement les
c'est ça qui me gêne c'est une comprends
c'est que moi je
j'aurais voulu qu'on règle ce compte
entre toi et moi qui n'ont pas toujours
tout s'est tu me fous la merde tu vois
j'aime pas ça quand les gens nous
regardent sur le manteau a été un
corrigé emballage ce soir là
la tabbee office récit suit tiré du mont
mais ta famille n'étant bien sûr je suis
comme un fou
voilà qui est déjà allé au musée grévin
pas vraiment non
la regardes tu espères y rentrer un jour
eh ben c'est pas en arrivant avec 2012
au connard tu seras ça tu fais là dedans
ici mes tracts en anglais c'est qu'il
est jean impassible on l'appelle
l'impassible gens vrais gens impassible
jean ferrat alors si tu veux te regarder
l'arbre ailleurs si on voit tout le
monde on voit la caméra cachée c'est un
défi comme je m'imagine c'est comme la
dame du lac qui passe une fois devant
l'asia le vif
[Musique]
si tu es un point g
si fort que je
[Musique]
je me tais
je me situe
3 ce n'est de respire
tu vois ce que je
sache que j'ai tout
je crois que tu
et que tu fais
elle
ce prêt est aussi mais le moineau miss
mackay
et son sérieux
tant qu'à sur des choses mais voilà
voilà voilà voilà
la dépravation voilà voilà dès que c'est
des nus ça te plait pas mal ça ça ma
voiture connaît tout de suite raymond
devos chapeau à part ça tu vois c'est la
partie du musée où tu peux espérer être
avec tes frasques vient voir parce que
je vais te montrer une autre partie du
musée où tu seras jamais qu'ils ne
feraient partie des musées bien par là
voilà où sont ils voilà par ici l'art
tiens voilà regarde diderot voilà là là
là voilà l'endroit où tu seras jamais
entre diderot d'alembert à toi car toi
qui a écrit une demi-ligne dans ta vie
tu l'avais cochée 11 ou pas crise les
prix le bruit c'est ça la classe il a
volé tiens tiens tiens pascal arese
voilà alors ça se passait je viens d'un
canton compte qu'ils n'avaient plus
d'idées billets les beaux mais on vous
connaît un peu il un peu rouge au pas
terrible avait changé ça t'aurait mais
ça fait ça alors je cherche vincent
perrot mais peut-être l'as nancy ii
selon lui des problèmes de peau ou
mirabeau
tu sais que tu aurais pas fait long feu
toi le monarchiste le royaliste truc
machin
voilà robert stone de france
notre bon pays voilà un truc bien aussi
faire avoue qu'elle est un peu pâle
maintenant maintenant que tu as vu le
bas ah non c'est toujours ça qui
l'intéressent lui sert à rien
j'espère que tout ça t'inspire un peu
parce que tout cet incident un peu un
peu plus de baaba j'espère oui voila je
suis quand même un peu navré de
constater que je t'emmène voir des
personnages historiques puis toi t'es
qu'une hâte c'est de courir retourner
voir claudia schiffer quoi c'est à dire
que tu pourras jamais de décrotter de ça
et en plus ce qui est pénible je
m'excuse de te le dire ce qui est
pénible c'est que quand je t'en fais le
reproche aux lieux humblement aux lieux
tranquillement 1 2 me dire ben oui j'ai
un peu exagéré je suis un peu idiot je
suis un peu léger je suis un peu frivole
et ben non talent est à l'air content de
toi en plus un dd voilà je te montre
voltaire je te montre pascal oui mais
maintenant tu regarde par terre mais
c'est pour faire ton cinéma c'est pour
faire ton cirque en fait y'a pas de
rédemption possible tu seras toujours
attiré par les boîtes de nuit les boîte
à partouze la drogue et les les verres
de whisky coca 1
j'essaye de te montrer des des endroits
où c'est
mettez ça et rien on te montre molière
terrain tu étais en train de ricaner de
chercher du haschich dans ta poche jeu
dont on te montre pascal tu étais en
train de penser aux fesses de claudia
schiffer que tu ne pourra même pas
touché en plus alors je comprend non
seulement de nom non seulement tu es des
voiliers mais en plus des mégalomanes tu
n'auras pas tout ça tu ferais mieux de
rentrer chez toi de lire un bon livre
tu ferais mieux d'aller regarder une
bonne pièce de théâtre tu ferais mieux
devra étudier un petit peu shakespeare
de mettre un petit peu de plomb dans la
tête banon toi il faut que tu sois là
mais un machin a dit loeb à oui ça y est
je crois que j'en ai fait le tour et les
le voile est il recommença à retourner
voir les espèces de drag kings queens
kling un dante en aidant dans des boîtes
à 300 mille balles le le whisky voilà
alors tu vas te plaindre après
évidemment tu entends ton voisinage ne
te regarde d'un drôle d'air ben je le
comprends moi je serai ton voisinage
aurait déménagé depuis longtemps du
nombre monsieur fait n'importe quelle
émission de télévision honte à proposer
des émissions culturelles c'est vrai
vous pas honte à proposer des émissions
sur l'histoire de france des émissions
sur la littérature non faut que tu
ailles faire des émissions sur les
whiskys les boîtes de nuit les les trucs
à partouzes de 2 buts à 1 aurier
benjamin va dire ne rien céder sur rien
si je sais ce que c'est ça qui m'attire
dans ce qui t'attire vais te le dis
cette série mais ce qui les attire c'est
le destin qui me fait marrer le pognon
et s'épanouissent titan nuit c'est que
pascal évidemment il n'a pas gagné
beaucoup de pognon en attendant s'agit
là surtout les mecs sur le mari
pascalien lui rapporter gros surtout les
billets pascal
oui mais voilà toit ce qui t'intéresse
dans pascal c'est le billet de banque et
tu cours après
et aujourd'hui j'ai dû bien sur la scène
d'un théâtre pour quoi faire eh ben pour
chercher s'il n'y a pas encore de trois
pièces de monnaie qui traînent par terre
voilà c'est tout ce qu'il ya des fleurs
remarque oui oui ben c'est comme t'as
pas vu le spectacle tu vas me demander
pourquoi je te le dirai pas t'as qu'à
venir alors là c'est pas des vraies
fleurs tac à venir ça c'est ça alors là
tu dis ou encore un peu il les a même
pas payer son entrée avec tout le fric
que tu gagnes à produire des émissions
ici sur la une la deux l'a3 l'a12 l'a15
et tout ça monsieur ardisson veut monter
un empire il se prend pour un américain
dérisoire tu ferais mieux de te retirer
sur un petit coin de terre 1 avec ta
femme et tes enfants et vivre comme un
honnête homme en réfléchissant un peu à
boire un bon verre de lait le matin
manger une bonne galette de blé que ta
femme fera cuire gentiment dans un four
artisanal un boulot d'être là à te
remplir le nez avec je ne sais quelle
cochonnerie qui font que tu ne sais même
pas arriver à l'heure au moins deux
rendez vous qu'est ce que tu veux que je
te dise
et encore je me retiens mon ami si c'est
pour aller de coucher oui mais non non
si c'est pour retourner
qu'est ce que tu vas faire madame zi
qu'est ce que tu as fait du porno
amateur voilà et on y est voilà
et voilà pourquoi ils pensaient à
claudia schiffer et bien alors les
sujets ardisson ils sont diversifiées il
ya un type qui fait du porno amateur
un type qui fait du porno
professionnelle puis lendemain c'est 2
qui passe est très différent ça nous
aide deux teams qui font du porno
amateur et l'autre va passer
professionnel abinan mail à notre grand
sujet c'est des professionnels du pape
et je décide de passer à maintenant
pourquoi pas mais j'ai envie simplement
ça c'est varié ça ça va leur plaire à la
chaîne un petit peu de cul comme ça puis
après un qu'est-ce que vous avez 21
types il fait l'érotisme
mais les amateurs ou professionnels un
passant s'est passé ça le sujet
justement on enquête un petit peu on se
demande
voilà voilà les recettes
aujourd'hui tu veux venir heureusement
qu'il me reste si tu veux venir françois
c'est ce que je veux venir je me faisais
tu commencé si je viens je devrais voir
à quelle vitesse je vais vous mettre
tout ça en prison marianne voilà voilà
voilà ce qui est beau moi je veux bien
venir et puis le redis il leur montrait
la beauté d'un d'une petite fleur de
colza pour essayer qu'il retrouve un
sentiment une espèce de toutes petites
pureté si c'est possible mais non ils
font du porno amateur
qu'est ce que tu veux je disais déjà
content du porno amateur 1 il n'y a rien
enfin écoute au moins ici tu aura pris
un petit bain j'espère deviendra
piétonnière de voilà tu peux l'air de
quelque chose et une reine dans dix
quinze ans va te dire oui il ya autre
chose
y aller pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou